♪ ♪
>> JEFF SESSIONS HAD NO CHOICE
BUT TO RECUSE HIMSELF.
WHEN THE CAMPAIGN BECAME SUBJECT
OF AN INVESTIGATION.
HE WAS PART OF THE CAMPAIGN.
>> PAUL MANAFORT OUGHT TO BE
JAILED.
MOST LIKELY I THINK SHOULD FACE
SERIOUS CRIMINAL PENALTIES FOR
WITNESS TAMPERING.
>> IF PAUL DIDN'T FOLLOW THE
RULES WHEN HE WAS LOBBING
OVERSEAS AND DIDN'T DISCLOSE
THAT, THAT HE'S RESPONSIBLE.
IF HE'S BEEN TRYING TO GET
PEOPLE TO FALSIFY INFORMATION,
THEN HE'S RESPONSIBLE FOR THAT
ALSO.
>> THE QUESTION FOR US, IF
YOU'RE GOING TO BE A WITNESS AS
TO WHY COMEY WAS FIRED, HOW DID
HE STAY INVOLVED?
>> Bret: DEVELOPMENTS ON THE
HILL TO BE ABOUT RUSSIA
INVESTIGATION.
PAUL MANAFORT, THE MUELLER FOLKS
LOOKING AT POSSIBLE WITNESS
TAMPERING, AS HE COMMUNICATES
WITH ASSOCIATES.
I THEN PETER STRZOK WITH THE FBI
HAD TO HAVE MORE OF A ROLE IN
ALL THIS.
MEANWHILE THE PRESIDENT TWEETING
THIS MORNING:
"THE RUSSIAN WITCH HUNT HOAX
CONTINUES, ALL BECAUSE JEFF
SESSIONS DIDN'T TELL ME HE WAS
GOING TO RECUSE HIMSELF.
I WOULD HAVE QUICKLY PICKED
SOMEONE ELSE.
SO MUCH TIME AND MONEY WASTED,
SO MANY LIVES RUINED.
AND SESSIONS KNEW BETTER THAN
MOST THAT THERE WAS
NO COLLUSION!"
HE WRITES AGAIN:
"WHAT IS TAKING SO LONG WITH THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL'S REPORT ON
CROOKED HILLARY AND SLIPPERY
JAMES COMEY.
NUMEROUS DELAYS.
HOPE REPORT IS NOT BEING CHANGED
AND MADE WEAKER!
THERE ARE SO MANY HORRIBLE
THINGS TO TELL, THE PUBLIC HAS
THE RIGHT TO KNOW.
TRANSPARENCY!"
WITH THAT, LET'S BRING THE
PANEL.
MOLLIE HEMINGWAY, SEEN IN HER
EDITOR AT "THE FEDERALIST."
MARA LIASSON, NATIONAL CLINICAL
CORRESPONDENT AT NATIONAL PUBLIC
RADIO AND TOM ROGAN, COMETARY
RATER FOR "WASHINGTON EXAMINER"
RATER FOR "WASHINGTON EXAMINER""
>> I THINK WE ARE VERY ANXIOUS
WITH THE INSPECTOR GENERAL
REPORT AND WE WERE TOLD IT
WOULD, IN JANUARY, MARCH, APRIL,
MAY, JUNE.
STILL WAITING.
WE SHOULD HAVE APPROPRIATE
EXPECTATIONS ABOUT WHAT WILL BE
IN THAT REPORT.
OBVIOUSLY IT'S TAKING LONGER
BECAUSE THEY ARE FINDING WHERE
THEY NEED TO COVER AND I'M SURE
THEY'LL BE A LOT OF SALACIOUS
AND INTERESTING DETAILS AS WERE
ALREADY REVEALED WITH REGARD TO
ANDREW MCCABE WHEN THEY DETAILED
JUST ONE INSTANCE OF HIM LEAKING
TO THE MEDIA AND THE LYING UNDER
OATH HE DID.
THAT WAS THE NUMBER TWO AT THE
FBI FEUD.
PEOPLE SHOULD BE AWARE THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL CANNOT COMPEL
TESTIMONY FROM ANYONE OUTSIDE
THE AGENCY.
MANY PEOPLE HAVE LEFT EITHER BY
BEING FIRED OR OTHERWISE
LEAVING.
IT'S IMPORTANT WE HAVE OTHER
INDEPENDENT PEOPLE ARE ABLE TO
INVESTIGATE, SUCH AS CONGRESS,
WHICH IS AN AGENCY THAT HAS
SUBPOENAED INFORMATION FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE HAVE BEEN
SOMEONE QUITE A BIT OVER THE
COURSE OF THE INVESTIGATION.
>> Bret: MARA, THE IG DEALS
WITH THE CLINTON EMAIL
INVESTIGATION BUT HAS BEEN
EXTENDED TO THE BEGINNING OF THE
TRUMP-RUSSIA PROBE.
>> HE IS GOING TO BE LOOKING AT
THOSE THINGS.
ONE THING THAT STRUCK ME ABOUT
TODAY WAS DONALD TRUMP ONCE
AGAIN KIND OF TORTURING HIS
ATTORNEY GENERAL, SAYING IF I'D
ONLY KNOWN HE WAS GOING TO
RECUSE HIMSELF, I WOULD HAVE
PICKED SOMEONE ELSE.
AND WE NEVER WOULD'VE HAD THIS
INVESTIGATION.
JEFF SESSIONS HAS TOLD A LOT OF
SUPPORT, ESPECIALLY IN THE
SENATE.
HE WAS A SENATOR.
HEARD THAT THE SENATE LEADERSHIP
HAS COMMUNICATED WITH THE
WHITE HOUSE THAT THEY WOULD BE
UNLIKELY TO CONFIRM ANY OTHER
ATTORNEY GENERAL IF DONALD TRUMP
DID GO AHEAD AND FIRE JEFF
SESSIONS.
JEFF SESSIONS STILL KIND OF
BEING HUNG OUT TO DRY BY THE
PRESIDENT BY MAINTAINING A LOT
OF SUPPORT AMONG HIS PAST
COLLEAGUES.
>> Bret: TOM, THE MANAFORT
TEAM SAYING WE'RE GOING TO FIGHT
THIS IN COURT.
WE ARE HEARING REPORTS THAT
THERE IS A WITNESS TAMPERING
ALLEGATION THAT THE MUELLER
FOLKS ARE MAKING.
THE COMMUNICATION EARLY ON
MANAFORT MAY HAVE HAD WITH
ASSOCIATES.
HOW DO YOU LOOK THAT IN THE BIG
PICTURE ABOUT WE DON'T KNOW
ABOUT THE MUELLER PROBE?
>> PAUL MANAFORT HAS GROWING
PROBLEMS.
THE MIND BOGGLES AS TO WHY HE
WOULD ENGAGE IN THIS ACTIVITY,
IF HE DID.
IT'S NOT THAT HARD TO GET INSIDE
THESE COMMUNICATIONS.
MORE BROADLY ON THE PART OF THE
PRESIDENT, THIS EFFORT TO BRING
THE MUELLER INVESTIGATION,
ANYTHING RELATED TO COLLUSION
INTO THE PUBLIC SPHERE WHERE THE
PRESIDENT QUITE CONFIDENTLY
BELIEVES HE CAN WIN THE DEBATE
AND PUSH MUELLER OUT.
IN REFERENCING JEFF SESSIONS
AGAIN, THAT'S, AS MOLLIE
SUGGESTS, IN REFERENCE TO THE
UPCOMING IG REPORT WHICH I THINK
THE ADMINISTRATION WILL USE TO
WEAPONIZE.
SOMETHING TO LOOK FOR IN THE
COMING WEEKS IS FELIX.
HE WILL BE COMING OUT IN
RELATION TO MUELLER.
THEY THINK IT WILL STRENGTHEN
THEIR CASE.
I THINK IT IS COMING TO A HEAD.
>> Bret: I AGREE.
THAT'S HOW IT FEELS.
BUT WE DON'T KNOW WHAT WE DON'T
KNOW.
LET'S TURN, SPEAKING OF
SESSIONS, THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
SPEAKING ABOUT THE WHOLE
ALLEGATION AND THEY CHARGE A
FAMILY SEPARATION WHEN IT COMES
TO IMMIGRATION AND EFFORTS ALONG
THE BORDER.
>> THE LAW REQUIRES US TO KEEP
CHILDREN IN A DIFFERENT FACILITY
THEN WE DO FOR ADULTS.
EVERY TIME SOMEBODY GETS
PROSECUTED IN AMERICA FOR CRIME,
AMERICANS IN SIN, AND THEY GO TO
JAIL, THEY ARE SEPARATED FROM
WE DON'T WANT TO DO THIS AT ALL.
IF PEOPLE DON'T WANT TO BE
SEPARATED FROM THEIR CHILDREN,
THEY SHOULD NOT BRING THEM WITH
THEM.
>> Bret: THE PRESIDENT
TWEETING ALSO THIS MORNING:
"SEPARATING FAMILIES AT THE
BORDER IS THE FAULT OF BAD
LEGISLATION PASSED BY THE
DEMOCRATS.
BORDER SECURITY LAWS SHOULD BE
CHANGED BUT THE DEMS CAN'T GET
THEIR ACT TOGETHER!
STARTED THE WALL."
MOLLIE, DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S IN
LINE WITH WHAT WE KNOW.
>> THE FACT REMAINS THAT IF
CONGRESS WANTS TO CHANGE THE
LOST WHERE THEY SHOULD.
THERE'S A BIGGER ISSUE AT PLAY
WHICH IS WE HAVE TO COPE
COMPUTING IDEAS.
YOU EITHER HAVE BORDERS AND LAWS
THAT ENFORCE THE BORDERS OR YOU
DON'T.
IF YOU HAVE BORDERS AND HAVE
LAWS TO ENFORCE THE BORDERS,
DOESN'T MEAN ANYONE WHO WANTS TO
COME IN GETS TO COME IN UNDER
ANY CIRCUMSTANCES.
THERE ARE VERY DIFFICULT
SITUATIONS INVOLVING PEOPLE WHO
WERE FLEEING COUNTRIES AND
SEEKING REFUGEE STATUS, DOESN'T
MEAN IT'S AUTOMATICALLY GRANTED
OR AUTOMATICALLY QUALIFY.
WE SHOULD STOP TALKING ABOUT
THESE SORT OF EXTREME SITUATIONS
AND DEAL WITH THE REALLY
FUNDAMENTAL ISSUE OF OUR
IMMIGRATION POLICY, WHETHER
MEETS THIS COUNTRY'S NEEDS AND
WHETHER IT'S SATISFYING WITH THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE WANT.
THEY ARE NOT GETTING A LOT OF
GOOD DESCRIPTIONS OF THE
CONGRESSIONAL.
>> Bret: MARA, THERE'S NOT A
SENSE CONGRESS IS MOVING QUICKLY
OR AT ALL.
>> NO, BUT WITH SO CONFUSING IF
YOU HAVE JEFF SESSIONS SAYING WE
ARE GOING TO SEPARATE FAMILIES
FROM THEIR CHILDREN.
IT IS MEANT TO BE A DETERRENT,
LIKE YOU HEARD THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL SAY.
IF YOU DON'T WANT TO BE
SEPARATED FROM YOUR KIDS, DON'T
COME HERE.
THEN YOU HAVE DONALD TRUMP,
INSTEAD OF SUPPORTING THE POLICY
OF THE ADMINISTRATION COMMITTEE
IS SOMEHOW BLAMING IT ON
DEMOCRATS.
IT'S PRETTY CONFUSING.
I THINK HE FEELS SENSITIVE ABOUT
THE CRITICISM THE ADMINISTRATION
HAS GOTTEN FOR SEPARATING KIDS